un an pratiquement jour pour jour après
son prix nobel de physique georges
charpak est à la une du magazine envoyé
spécial ce soir sur france 2 à 20h50
dans un reportage inédit signé philippe
rochot georges charpak raconte les
bouleversements de sa vie familiale et
professionnelle
morceaux choisis
je vous invite à les recevoir entre pris
tellement de sa majesté le roi
je savais que c'était un moment fugace
que c'était quelque chose qu'il fallait
cueillir essayer de le savourer j'ai
essayé le savourer des châteaux margaux
les vendanges tardives mais exige de
redoutables et là aussi que j'arrête
c'est la première fois que georges
charpak parvenait à prendre des vacances
depuis son prix nobel de physique en
octobre 92 et temps en temps il propres
ancêtres le moment où les français
mettent en or et là vous êtes avec vos
petits enfants c'est rare dont ces rares
avec le fruit ne sais pas ce que tu es
s'enquiert du grand soif alors vous
émeut pas plus a rapidement vu une fois
la télé leur mère leur a dit regardez il
ya georges ont dit oui mon la diable
c'est très bien il vaut ramène aux
problèmes fondamentaux
la suite c'est ce soir à 20h50 sur notre
antenne sur france 2